PROFESSOR: Let's
define a few familiar
and standard operations on sets.
So here's a picture
of two sets A and B,
where the idea is that
the circle represents
the points in A. The
other circle represents
the points in B. The overlapping
area, this lens-shaped region,
are the points that
are in both A and B.
And the background
are the points that
are in neither A and B.
So this sort of
a general picture
allows you to classify
points with respect to And B,
and it's called a Venn diagram,
in this case for two sets.
It's still useful
for three sets.
It gets more complicated
for four sets.
And after that point, they're
not really very useful.
But a lot of the
basic operations
can be illustrated
nicely in terms
of the Venn diagram
for two sets,
and that's what
we're about to do.
So the first operation is union.
It's the set of points
shown here in magenta.
It's the set of points that are
in either A or B, all of them.
And so if we were
defining this in terms
of set-theoretic notation
or predicate notation,
the union symbol-- the
U is the union symbol.
So A union B is defined to be
those points x that are in A OR
are in B.
And you can already begin to
see an intimate relationship
between the union operation
and the propositional OR
connective.
But don't confuse them.
If you apply an OR to
sets, your compiler
is going to give
you a type error.
And if you apply union to
propositional variables,
your compiler is also going
to give you a type error.
So let's keep the
propositional operators
and the set-theoretic
operators separate
[? and ?] clearly
distinct even though they
resemble each other.
All right.
Next basic operation is
intersection where, again, it's
the points that are
both in A and B,
the points in common, which
are now highlighted in blue.
So the definition of
A intersection B--
we use an upside-down union
symbol for intersection--
it's the set of points
that are in A and are in B.
So let's stop for
a minute and make
use of the similarity between
the set-theoretic operations
and the propositional operators.
Let's look at a set-theoretic
identity, which I claim
holds no matter what sets A,
B, and C you're talking about.
And we're going to
prove it by making
the connection between
set-theoretic operations
and propositional operators.
And so let's read the thing.
It says that if you take A
union the set B intersection
C, that's equal to the
set A union B intersected
with A union C. Now, let's
not think through yet
how to make this an
intuitive argument.
It's going to really crank
out in an automatic way
in a moment.
But we can remember
it as saying that you
can think of this as union
distributing over intersection.
So if you think of
union as times here
and intersection
as plus, then we've
got a rule that says
that A times B plus C is
A times B plus A times C.
Now, it's also true that if
you reverse the role of union
and intersection, you get
another distributive law
that AND distributes over
union, but never mind that.
Let's just look at this one.
We're trying to prove the
distributive law for union
over intersection.
How shall we prove it
just from the definitions?
Well, the way we're
going to do it
is by showing that the two
sets on the left-hand side
and the right-hand side have
the same set of elements.
Namely, if I have
an element x that
appears in the set described
on the left-hand side,
then that point is in
the right-hand side.
And it's an if and only if.
So that says that the left-hand
side and the right-hand side
expressions defines sets
with the same set of points.
This holds for all x.
And it turns out
that the proof is
going to follow by analogy
to a propositional formula
that we're going to make
use of in the proof.
That was a propositional
equivalence
that we proved in an
earlier talk, namely
that OR distributes over AND.
So P OR Q AND R is equivalent
to P OR Q AND P OR R.
So you can see this
equivalence in purple
has the same structure as the
set-theoretic equality in blue,
except that union's
replaced by OR,
intersection's replaced
by AND, and set
variables A, B, C is replaced
by propositional variables
P, Q, R.
So let's just remember
that we've already
proved this propositional
equivalence,
and we're going to make use of
it in the middle of this proof
that these two sets are equal.
So again, we said we
were going to prove
the two sets are
equal by showing
they have the same points.
So here's the proof.
It's going to be a lovely if and
only if argument the whole way.
So looking at the left-hand
side, a point x is in A union
B intersection C by
definition of union
if and only if x is an A OR
x is in B intersection C.
I've just applied the
definition of union there.
OK.
Now, let's look at
this expression.
x is in B intersection
C. That's the same
as x is in B AND x is
in C, again, just using
the definition of intersection.
And now I have a propositional
formula involving OR and AND
and the basic assertions about
sets of x is a member of one
of those A's, B's, C's.
Now, at this point,
I can immediately
apply my propositional
equivalence
and say that the assertion x is
an A OR x is in B AND x is in C
holds if and only if
this expression, x is
an A OR x is in B AND x is in
A OR x is in C. Why is that?
Well, I'm just invoking the
propositional equivalence.
Let's look at it.
That if I think of the x
is in A as proposition P--
and let's replace all the
x [? over ?] A's by P--
and I think of x is in B as
a Q and x is in C as an R,
then I can see that the first
set-theoretic assertion has
the form of P OR Q AND R.
And I can transform it by
the propositional equivalence
into P OR Q AND P OR
R. And then remember
what P and R are to get back to
the set-theoretic membership,
basic membership assertions.
So now we've just
proved that x is
in A OR x is in B AND
x is in A OR x is in C.
And that's if and only if it
was in the left-hand side set.
Well, now I'm going to
go back the other way.
Namely, this OR, that
x is in A OR x is in B,
is the same as saying
that x is in A union B,
likewise here just by applying
the definition of union.
And this assertion that
x is in this set AND x
is in this set is the
same as saying that x
is in their intersection.
And I've completed
my proof, namely
the point that was in the
left-hand side if and only
if it's in the right-hand side.
You have to remember that
that was the right-hand side
of the identity.
So this is a general
method actually,
where you can take any
set-theoretic equality
involving union and
intersection and the operations
of difference and complement
that we'll talk about
in a moment, and we can convert
any such set-theoretic equality
into a propositional equality
or a propositional equivalence
so we can check that the
propositional assertion is
an equivalence.
And from that, using this method
of converting the membership
statements in the set
expression into a propositional
combination, we can check,
and automatically check,
any kind of set-theoretic
identity involving
union, intersection, and minus.
And that, in fact, is the
way that automatic engines
like Mathematica can prove
these set-theoretic identities.
So let's just for the record
put down that last operation.
The difference
operation is the set
of elements that are
in A AND not in B.
So we'd write it as A minus
B is the set of points that
are in A AND not in B.
and it's Illustrated
by this region that's
highlighted in orange.
And a special case of the minus
operation or the difference
operation is complement.
When you know the overall domain
that you expect all your sets
to be part of, then you
can define a complement
to be everything that's not
in A-- the set of x such
that x is not in A, where x
is understood to be ranging
over some domain of discourse.
So if we're going to
picture that, we're
looking at the whole orange
region, all of the stuff that's
not in A if we think
of the whole slide
as representing the
domain of discourse D.